à la haute autorité de santé donne ses
recommandations ce qui concerne la
campagne de vaccination prévue dès la
fin de l'année compte tenu du nombre
limité des doses
l'organisme recommande de vacciner en
premier les résidents des ehpad et
préconise 5 face progressive et une
ligne directrice protéger en priorité
les plus vulnérables et ceux qui s'en
occupent mais six français sur dix n'ont
pas l'intention de se faire vacciner
selon un dernier sondage ifop écouter
ces quelques réactions recueillies par
sébastien dufour pour l'instant plutôt
pour après il faudra voir ce que ça
implique au niveau des effets
secondaires etc
mais évidemment plutôt couronne
apparemment chat je ne sais pas pour
l'instant je peux pas vous répondre donc
on l'envoie par la suite les médecins
les infirmières voilà à tous les gens
qui travaillent à l'hôpital je pense que
c'est en premier d'accord les gens à
alger aussi
ouais j'ai plutôt envie d'avoir
confiance suis un optimiste j'attends de
voir déjà les premiers vaccins ce que ça
va donner
voir surtout si on a des réactions
secondaires pour les personnes qui peut
sites contaminés ou pas pour l'instant
je sais qu'il ya beaucoup de nouveaux
qui font des tests
ils ont tous tendance à mettre la barre
un peu haut j'attends de voir surtout
les premiers résultats
aaron me vexe faire vacciner moi même ou
pas j'attends qu'on me donne confiance
en fait que je puisse avoir confiance au
vaccin qu'on va proposer